the polar icecaps are melting droughts
and storms are becoming more common
across the globe a recent study found
that the concentration of greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere has never risen
as fast as it did last year one place
that's been hit especially hard by
rising sea levels is Fiji in the South
Pacific now for the first time Fiji
will be chairing the UN climate
conference prime minister Frank Bynum
Adama will be leading the negotiations
environmentalists say Fiji is a warning
for the world Fiji has been especially
hard-hit by climate change because of
rising sea levels Fiji was the first
place in the world for an entire village
had to be relocated because of climate
change the Bonn meeting aims to flesh
out the terms of the 2015 Paris climate
agreement almost all countries have
signed the Accord only the US has
announced it as pulling out the DIA
requires that temperatures did not climb
by more than two degrees
it requires all countries to set their
own climate goals it paves the way for
billions in aid especially for poor
countries bond will be a working
conference without big decisions like
those made in Paris at first it sounds
pretty unspectacular but what we agreed
on in Paris in December 2015 is like a
new worldwide law and something like
that needs rules of interpretation but
Donald Trump's stated intention to
withdraw from the Paris Accord has cast
a shadow over these talks so far other
countries do not share his view the
major storms in the Caribbean combined
with the US backing out of the Paris
agreement have increased the feeling of
unity among the other countries many
feel it is now time to take action the
results of climate change are becoming
more and more dramatic and not only in
Fiji